apenas unos meses después de que las
altas temperaturas bacheeran Records en
toda Europa y otras partes del mundo un
informe de la UNESCO confirma lo que
temen los científicos que investigan el
cambio climático un tercio de los
glaciares de los sitios del patrimonio
mundial habrán desaparecido en 2050
aunque reduzcamos las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero los glaciares se
están derritiendo en lugares
emblemáticos como los parques nacionales
de Yellowstone y ya se Michi así como
los últimos glaciares que quedan en
África según el informe los glaciares
del patrimonio mundial pierden cada año
58 mil millones de toneladas de hielo Lo
que equivale al volumen total de agua
que utilizan Francia y España juntas
cada año el 50% de la humanidad depende
de forma directa o indirecta de los
glaciares como fuente de agua para el
uso doméstico la agricultura y la
hidroelectricidad los glaciares en el
hábitat natural de varias especies entre
ellas los osos polares que corren el
riesgo de extinguirse por hombre a
finales de siglo ya que la crisis
climática provoca la desaparición del
mar Ártico en otras partes del mundo
millones de personas están expuestas al
riesgo de inundaciones debido a la
subida del nivel del mar provocada por
el deshielo está rápida desaparición de
los glaciares se debe a un factor
principal el calentamiento global según
el estudio dos tercios de los glaciares
restantes del patrimonio mundial podrían
salvarse si el calentamiento global se
limita a 1,5 grados Celsius pero la ONU
ha advertido que las promesas climáticas
aún no son ni de lejos suficientes para
alcanzar este objetivo